[Inaudible].
All right. So today we are going to talk about money.
I was inspired by Stephen Graham because he was talking about his multiple
income sources, but because I'm an idiot or a baller, you know,
tomato, tomato,
I feel like it's more fitting that I show you guys my reckless spending.
So as you know,
I got $45,000 in bonus with my new software engineering job.
So what I did was that I took $19,000 of it and put it
into my 401k so that the company, dude, I'm kidding, man, dude,
I'm not a loser. I don't do 401ks. Also, you didn't click this video for this.
You clicked it for my reckless spending.
So I'm going to show you so as you can see,
if I do see my spending over time, it's pretty much a hockey stick.
I mean, usually people would be pretty happy about hockey stick graph,
but I mean, if this is my spending, so I don't think that's a great thing.
So as you can see, according to this, my last month spending was
$18,900. And well, I mean,
you know, I mean,
we should dig deeper into it because it's not always accurate because sometimes
the program, they, they look at transfers and they think that suspending,
but it's actually not,
or actually spend more and it just wasn't recorded on this program.
So we're going to try to export all of that into an Excel spreadsheet and then
I'll dive deep into it. All right, before we continue this video,
I just want to say that viewers discretion is advice.
I made this video for entertainment purposes.
Please do not spend all your money recklessly like me.
And you have to know that my net worth is totally fine.
It has been growing faster than ever.
So please spend responsibly did not
do like me. It's only for entertainment.
And if you're wondering, how is my net worth still growing so fast,
despite me spending so much? Well, I'm not going to tell you,
is it because I'm a trust fund, baby? I don't know.
Is it because of my Bitcoins?
I don't know,
enjoy the video.
So I'm having, I'm having problems with the autofocus.
So I'm going to have to put this in the background.
So in case you were wondering why I have a Bitmoji, this is what I use it for.
All right. Okay. There we go.
All right.
So now what we're going to do is I'm going to rename the description just for
one's, uh, privacy reasons and also too,
so that I actually remember what it is because now sometimes the names are quite
cryptic. It doesn't mean anything. So I'm going to do that first.
And then secondly, what I'm going to do,
I'm going to separate them into buckets of spendings.
Cause I don't like the preset spendings that they use.
So I'm going to bucket them into birthday gift, a business expense,
charity, entertainment, food, uh, I don't,
f-ing no materialistic desires, medical, other rent,
self-improvement transportation and travel. Before you ask me what they are,
I'm going to go through them. Okay. So don't worry about it.
And I don't even know it's just because I didn't want to sort them anymore.
There were a lot of small purchases from Amazon and I didn't, I don't have time.
I don't have time to sort through all of them. Okay. All right. So I got it.
I did a lot of data cleaning cause you know, I'm a, I'm a data scientist.
So I ordered it by the amount spent.
So you could see it in order of amount spent. All right.
So let's go to the summary now. Uh, I made a pivot table and then you know,
a graph because why not? Honestly it's not even necessary.
But if you look at the breakdown, the,
the biggest expense is this line here, which is materialistic desires,
which is everything that's really at the shopping and stuff that I don't need.
So that is the highest spending with $4,000.
And then the next highest is entertainment. That is like concerts.
What else?
It's like concerts, comedy shows, stuff like that.
And then here it's like business expense. This is related to like cameras.
Anything that I need to run my YouTube channel. Well, I mean,
I actually don't need it. It's more okay, fine.
Some of it can go to materialistic spending, but it's related to YouTube.
So I'll put it in business expense. And then we have food,
which is a thousand dollars,
which includes restaurants actually only includes restaurants.
I never do groceries. So it's, it's mainly restaurants. And then we got rent,
which is my rent. I mean, I don't pay 4,600.
I don't know if you saw my other video. And I said, I paid 4,600 chill,
man. I have roommates. It was only clickbait. Okay. I only pay 1900.
And then we have self-improvement,
which is the smallest bucket of my spending for self-improvement.
I have a personal training and maybe audible or something like
that. But yeah, as you can see, I'll spend a lot on that.
I don't do a lot of self-improvement and then transportation,
which is like Uber. It's what?
The $1,000 did I might as well
rent a Tesla or something. So here it says 22,000.
I'm not sure if that's true.
Maybe like I'm going to like clean it up a little bit. Okay.
So let's look at it. Deep dive style. So monthly rent,
$1,900. Okay. The Apple watch,
Adam is 1400 K con LA tickets.
I bought three of them. So this shouldn't really be 1300.
I should divide this by three. So let's see just by three.
So then $1,000 for my new bedsheets bedding duvet and all that totally
worth it. Because now when I sleep naked, it feels like, you know,
so silky hands are all over my body. It feels really good.
And then here is Hamilton tickets. I bought a Hamilton ticket for my brother,
his fiance and me and yeah, it's on me. So this one,
I have to leave it there because even though I bought three of them,
they're not paying me back. All right. And then next we have eight X. Oh,
this is Trevor Noah. Yeah. So for Trevor Noah,
I bought two tickets. That was um, yeah, that was for me.
And then they're a friend and that costs 964.
I can divide that by two because they're not paying me back. Okay.
And then I bought a pixel three XL. Uh it's right here.
Why did I buy it? Um, no idea. I think it's like,
it's a hedge, you know,
in case one day Android becomes better than iPhone or that one day,
um, iPhones are not cool anymore.
So at least the transition will be a lot easier for me because I,
now I use both.
So it's a lot easier for me to transition into Android when the time comes.
And then the next spending three of them, $640.
That is my flight ticket to Japan because I am going to Japan this year. Uh,
I bought them for my friends, but they will pay me back.
So I will delete these two. Okay. Oh wait. Oh.
I want to say the joke. I want it to say. Oh yeah.
And the reason why I bought three tickets to Japan is because I want both of the
seat next to me to be empty. So I bought all three of them, but no,
I'm not that rich. And then all right,
$633. This is a business expense is it's,
it's kind of like a box it's for doing live videos, using my camera. Uh,
I use it for my tech interview. Pro might as well plug tech interview pronoun.
Good news.
We added new videos about system design and also about how to transition into
software engineering.
And then the reason why I bought this live video thing is that we do live videos
every two weeks for the Facebook group.
And then you could ask us Q and A's and stuff like that. If you're interested,
click on tech interview product com. All right.
And then next we got Ticketmaster.
What is this? 544 bucks?
What did I buy? I don't remember
the the that I buy it.
July 4th.
What the?
Oh, got it. Got it. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Got it. Oh yeah.
So I bought tickets for Allie Wong front seat. Okay. Actually not front seat,
the, the road before the front seat, because I don't want to get,
I don't want them to talk to me while they do their show because I always get
nervous. So next we have, wow. That's a lot.
We have four Facebook, uh, charges.
Two of them is for advertising. I mean, you know,
how do you expect my channel to grow? You really think that I make good content,
which is how I grow my channel. Don't be so naive.
I pay for my subscribers. And then the other two is, uh,
for mental health America, which is a charity. Uh,
I'm doing a fundraiser and I put in $500. Uh, it's not a thousand,
so this is wrong. Cause uh, I kind of did it twice by accident.
So it's only $500. I'll talk about that later. I don't want to,
I don't want you guys to think I'm a good person or anything. All right.
And then, Oh, $440. That is my virtual assistant.
I pay for a virtual assistance so that they can manage my calendar.
They can respond to some emails that can help me do some invoicing and stuff
like that. Very useful.
Highly recommended if you're rich and then the next one Tom on,
that's actually just a guitar. So I bought a guitar. Uh,
you could see it right here.
Yeah.
Let's see. And then he got a lot of, uh, business expense here.
Zapier or press Venmo. What the did I buy WordPress? I don't know. Okay.
Some of it is pretty dumb. Okay. I guess you got the gist of it.
You got the bulk of my spending and let's go back to the pivot table
and see how it looks. It's not that bad.
It's it's it's it's still $19,000. Okay. Hmm. Crazy thing. Honestly,
I am okay with everything,
but what the hell transportation is so high.
Let me look at that.
[Inaudible].
Live, live, live, live, live so clearly I like Uber more, but Holy.
$1,000. Is that right? Did I spend a thousand dollars in a month? Holy.
Did. I might as well just pay for a Tesla or something. Oh, you know what?
You live and learn. All right. Anyways.
So I'm going to wrap this video in terms of a money-wise. So as you can see,
travel $900. It's not that bad, actually transportation. $1,000.
I could do better in that.
Self-improvement I shouldn't worry about spending more in self-improvement but
clearly I don't care about my self improvement. That much rent 1900.
I can't change anything. Those are some utility costs, whatever other,
I don't want to go into that, but what isn't other, let me go check cash,
advance interest on what that is. Virtual assistant was an other, Oh,
maid cleaning service. I also put them other that's I recommend that too.
Especially if you're lazy. Right. So, okay. That's that's not that bad.
I'm not going to change anything there. Entertainment. I don't want to,
I don't want to change that because entertainment's important. Right? Uh,
let's go back and entertainment on. See what I pay for entertainment. Yeah.
Like, like totally worth it. Right. Spotify. I have to show time,
got to Hamilton tickets. You know, it's for my brother.
It's important to Fandango movie. Totally important. I don't know what, Oh,
in-flight wifi. That's important to Patrion on a white says Jim,
but Patrion. I got to support to Patrion members, Tiffany Young tickets.
K-pop really important. We're going to skip this one.
We're going to skip that one. Nintendo digital. I can take that off.
It's only $4 Trevor. Noah. That was worth it. That was really no. I mean,
what are you going to do with your money?
If you're not going to have fun with it. K con LA tickets totally worth it.
Allie Wong totally worth it. So yeah.
I'm not going to change anything in my entertainment, business expense.
Dude's business expense. Mantz you know, to recap. Yes.
I spent a lot this month, but that's probably not every month.
I hope. And there's two reasons why I spend so much.
The first reason is consumption, smoothing. All right. It's an econ term.
Learn it every time. Every time I spend too much, that's my excuse.
I'm just doing consumption, smoothing.
And then the second reason is I don't plan on saving for retirement
because I'm banking on the fact that one of my investments will pan out
and will make me rich.
So that saving a few thousands here and there would be irrelevant.
Oh, what kind of investments? Stocks real estate Bitcoins. No, you plebs. Okay.
I'm investing in my future kids and banking on the fact that one of them will be
extremely rich and that will pay dividends to me.
It didn't work out for my parents,
but I'm optimistic for my kids.
I should really call my parents.
And new K-pop video. Anyways. Now I want to talk about the charity section.
So I got all these corgis from the thousand skies. So thank you so much,
but I don't know what to do with them.
I'm not going to keep them in my place forever.
So I decided to give them out in exchange for a donation to my
fundraiser in mental health America.
So that's when I decided to donate 500 to bootstrap my fundraiser so that it
doesn't look like a total failure if I don't have anyone donating.
So if you're in the Bay area, SF Bay area, you could, you know,
for a small donation, even just two bucks,
you could just give two bucks and then I could personally hand you the corgi and
I could meet. And like you give you a corgi,
but if you're not in the SF Bay area, unfortunately I can't deliver it to you.
But if you really want one,
you could go on thousand skies.com in case you want to know,
they're not paying me for this. I just really,
really liked the corgis because there's a sentimental value to it.
Um, if you watch my videos from the beginning, you would understand why it's,
because, uh,
many times I interacted with the corgi on one of my videos that went really,
really popular and I kind of associate my success to these corgis and,
uh, yeah. And I kind of want to pay homage to it anyways,
that's it for now the video is long enough on this. I edited it really well.
I'm not sure, but, uh, thanks for watching really appreciate it. And uh,
I'll leave some links down below, like for example,
the fundraiser Lang and the thousand skies link and yeah, I hope you enjoy it.
So I'll leave you with this. Don't spend recklessly spend responsibly,
but remember self-worth before work.
Yeah.